(man)
She's beautiful, she's smart,
she's sophisticated.
(woman)
Sophisticated.
(man)
She's your best friend.
(woman)
Best friend.
(man)
You can't picture your
life without her.
Or can you?
A little bit.
Sometimes.
(woman)
Occasionally.
(man)
Give her the gift that keeps
on giving... you more time.
(woman)
Time.
We're proud to introduce our
Stolen Years collection.
Because you're not sure
and you probably never will be.
(woman)
Stolen Years.
(man)
A line of jewelry
as gorgeous are her
and as non-committal as you.
(woman)
Who's that new chick
in marketing?
(man)
Stolen Years marks the precious
days and months you're taking
from her as you carelessly
diddle time away,
trying to figure out
if she's the best you can do.
The Stolen Years
collection.
Give her the gift
that says forever.
I will keep you waiting
for for-(bleep)-ever.
(woman)
Forever.